first of all uh good morning sir i
really want to start with a sincere
uh
congrats on the movie for real i wanna i
wanna start with that i have so many
questions and so much to talk about but
i like throwing a few curveballs at the
beginning uh which are some fun you know
this about me so if someone has actually
never seen and i don't know who these
people are but if someone has never seen
anything that you've done what is the
first thing you'd like them to watch and
why
you know the whole filmography of
everything
i would say that either
shape of water or pants labyrinths would
be great primers
of what i do
but now nightmare if they could watch
two i would say
pants and devil's backbone or shape of
water and nightmare alley and those are
sort of the alpha and the omega
of of what i do
you obviously um everyone knows you have
a very nice collection of uh interesting
things in your house and everywhere who
knows where it's all at what are some of
the newest things you've added to your
collection that you might want to tell
us about
well you know unlike yesterday for the
first time in
many many
many many months i had an afternoon free
and
i needed to
distract myself and i painted a model
it was
a model of um
yeah i don't know if you're familiar
with mobius
mobius's uh comic book rsac
i haven't read that no yeah arsegh
there was there was um
a beautiful beautiful model done by paul
harding
and he posted it on twitter
and i said would you please print me
a copy of that and he sent me a 3d
printing and yesterday i was just all
day painting the model and now it's on a
shelf
fully painted
uh please post a picture uh if you can
on uh i'll post one on twitter i guess
yes please um it's not finished it has
i do one pass in one day because i'm
very impatient and then i go back and
stipple and dry brush and do a
more flourishes and stuff like that yeah
i think people will forgive you if it's
not perfect yeah and i i hope they do
um of all the films you've made and you
think back on them what do you think
ended up being the toughest shot to pull
off
and why
you know
the two
the worst experience was mimic
the worst
the most difficult
have been pants and nightmare alley
nightmare was it was so
such a monster because i i'm being
completely candid here i thought this is
a great screenplay but
it is technically not very complicated
is you know
just uh
we're gonna design it
and then let the actors play within the
frame and it's gonna demand
uh
my attention but it's gonna be a fun
shoot this is how i went in and then the
movie
uh turned out to be
like
riding a bull
in every sense the movie kept asking
every day he kept asking new questions
of me
demanding uh
complete answers in a way that no other
material did because uh it was it was a
tonally really difficult movie uh it was
really uh
the language i was trying with the
camera
the language i was trying with
the reality of it all was very different
for me and it was it was an incredibly
wild ride then complicated by every
complication you would expect weather
stopping for covid restarting with covet
protocols
making that movie fit on a budget
with the spectacle i thought
it needed
et cetera et et cetera you can add all
the etc
you want and then
we ended up with a movie that was three
hours
20
and had to compress it and distill it
into two hours 19. you know
oh i have so many follow-ups to that oh
my god um
i'm going to get to the because i love
talking about the editing process but
i'll get to it in a few minutes what are
you
uh for people that have not seen the
marketing i guess what i want to say is
what are you most excited for people to
see about nightmare alley and your take
on this material well look the the the
first thing is
and the closest i've gone tonally to
this movie is devil's bible which which
was
80 percent
realistic and realism
and 10 15
fantastical elements this is all
realism in the sense that it is a
stylish movie it is elegant it is
beautiful uh it has the craftsmanship
but is not uh
supported by or by a fantastical
underpinning there's no creatures no
ghosts no
no fantastical elements you know and and
and i think uh that that is the thing
that i
i i'm addressing
uh and this is reality i think it's a
movie not about
the past but about today
in every possible way the the notions
the themes
the anguish the anxiety that the movie
has is of today
and that
that is the thing i tried to do because
noir noir is the one of the two genres
that more clearly reflects the time it
was made of made under like horror is
the other one horror and sci-fi fantasy
you know you have um the polls of the
cold war
and the noirs and the pulse of the cold
war and the movies uh made at that time
uh
then you have the post-vietnam horror
and the post vietnam noirs
and then you have the 80s neo-noirs and
each of their
those eras is reflected in this genre
and i wanted to do a movie that was set
in the past but spoke about today
obviously you were heavily influenced by
film noirs making this movie can you
stop can you talk about some of your top
top film noir inspirations
for um you know looking at for uh
nightmare alley
well visually i tried to move away from
it i tried to visually make it
a movie that happened in the real world
and not stylize it completely we did
follow up the chiaroscuro light of it
all but tried to avoid any of the
cliches like voice over
slow turning fans venetian blinds
wet street uh walked by a
detective in an overcoat all the things
that have become
sort of the dead men were no blade uh
sort of uh cliches we tried to avoid all
that and reinvented
but the influence
for me noir is a very
moral
uh
parable a very moral
oriented genre which
actually depends on the characters
decisions
to shape his destiny or her destiny you
know and and i was very influenced by
uh
there very rarely do you follow a
character that you don't know
if there is any possibility of
redemption
in the character the one that comes to
mind immediately is uh too late for
peers
let's let's cut is fantastic in that
movie because
she
is
unstoppable and and the the
we match that movie by creating the same
um black bag with money that she has in
the ending of that movie
there's uh strangers on a train there's
we match the marquee of the carnival
it's exactly the same marquee
than uh then robert walker walks in and
strangers on a train
other influences was a
fallen angel uh the auto premanger uh
fox noir the cafe on the beginning is
sort of a riff on that
uh but mainly it was the otto preminger
noirs at fox were the main influence you
know
you can you can see a very gritty
very dark
um
reckoning morally for those characters
and i think that that's what i wanted
very much
in this movie that it felt
like uh like uh
like it addressed those moral questions
of what happens when you have a populist
lion line
all the way to the top
and then finding
finding himself facing the truth at the
end you know
a hundred percent um you obviously uh
what was it about actually the nightmare
alley material that said i want to
remake this this is something i want to
spend two years of two or more years of
my life making almost four yeah almost
four
i think
first of all i never ever thought about
it as a remake because what i was trying
to address was the novel
and not only the novel but the biography
of the writer of the novel william
lindsey gresham which basically is the
central character of nightmare alley you
know
he left one of the notes he left uh
posthumously was uh
i am stan you know or stan is me you
know and i think
uh
uh when we were writing kim and i said
let's not refer
at all to the first movie let's
find our solutions through the novel and
what we know about uh
william segreton's
spiritual quest because he was in a
quest he's a guy that was looking into
buddhism tarot
psychoanalysis
even early dianetics
yoga
physical physical culture
it was an incredibly curious mind
that was fought on the republican side
on the lincoln brigade in the spanish
civil war
and that's where he heard about the geek
for the first time
uh his wife left him and married c.s
lewis
of narnia fame you know it's it his life
was
when he became very rich
from nightmare alley selling the rights
uh he
spent it in a way that was completely
irrational
and and but he was never completely
happy you felt and and part of it
what i wanted to show is a character
that starts
the movie with nothing
and then
gains
one two three times
possibilities of finding happiness and
he doesn't see them
he just thinks how there must be more
there must be more and i always say the
the idea of the nightmare being the flip
side of the american dream
that's what made me want to go do this
movie
yeah it's uh that's one of the things
that i loved about it is that you he
just is never he's never satisfied
and it's amazing because he
i don't want to i don't want to get into
specifics obviously but you know there's
a clear point where he is very
successful and has everything or has so
much and yet it's never enough
no there is in fact one of the things
that i loved in the novel and and that
we we were looking for very pointedly is
a happy ending in the middle
there's that beautiful crane
when he's leaving the carnival with the
girl the book
the code
everything he has everything to be happy
and and the crane goes to the sky and
it's like almost like a happy ending
and then
you cut
and it's two years later
he has a lot of money and he's
incredibly
unhappy
still and now he's unhappy with the girl
that he thought
was the reason
to live you know
his reason to to exist you know and and
i thought this is a really interesting
character
the idea of success which is something
that you grapple with as an as an artist
and as a storyteller the idea of
can you
can you grapple with that and find
happiness not not in what you
have but in what you don't lack
that's a big difference
the the rich man is not the man that has
a lot of money is the man that can give
most of what he has and be happy you
know i i really
these are questions that were
in my mind for the characters
um for people that are actually like you
say younger
movie fans that are not familiar with
the film noir genre um what are some of
the movies that they should start with
if they want to engage with that uh with
film noir
well i think the hardest noir
uh is for me
uh
the the one that i like i mean i i love
fallen angel i love uh too late for
tears as i said i love detour
i love um
in in my opinion all the sam fuller
noirs are great
when
where the sidewalk ends
uh born to kill
uh which is absolutely
brutal even now
you know and
the the
the
the cure there's curiosities like
there's two mickey rooney noirs that are
really unforgiving with the main
character and and they're very very
curious you know uh
i i think i think that uh i would start
with with the hardest ones because
it's a genre that has a lot to offer in
times of despair
is is that's the curious thing is it's a
genre that should be uh very much in
both right now you know because it's
perfect for our times
um so uh one of the things that i loved
about nightmare alley is that in all
your movies you tend to have monsters
and creatures and everything else but in
this film all the monsters are men and
you know it and and i loved that um can
you sort of talk about that aspect of
the film well look
the curious thing about nightmare alley
is that is is at the same time a big
departure of what i do and perfectly in
keeping with what i do
and in every movie
i do i always say
the the
the most brutal monster is man
and you know i'm 57 and
it was about time i i tried to do it
straight on you know i tried to do it
without any of the metaphors and any of
the
parabolic figures of the monsters and
just go and portrait them and
the the difficulties with the movie like
this is that you are following this
character
99.9 of the time
we never lose sight of him he is or
guide in and out of every situation
every single scene
he comes out of him or he goes into it
and and and uh that's a very difficult
exercise that this is
one of the things that made it so hard
how do we track
this guy where he is at
and what he's thinking
look it came to be so crazy and exercise
that
often i said we know more about this
character if we keep him in the shadows
we know what he's thinking more if he's
in the shadows or his back to us and the
camera just sees him thinking from
behind
these are devices we thought about the
uh bradley the cinematographer and
myself we said let's try that because
obviously you need the complicit
uh partnership i had with bradley to to
do this because i would say
he would joke that i would light put
more light on the
on the cyclopean unborn baby
than on him you know and i said well
there's a little bit of truth to that
and these are the reasons and i think
and then we would joke with this another
where we said no light this is a
close-up for bradley you know
but but i but i think uh
i think that that but if you look at my
characters and i think the the the the
caretake the the caretaker in devil's
bag one is sort of stan
you know is a prince without a kingdom
that believes he deserves more the
captain of ben's labyrinth is a little
bit like that
and and um
you know i think that
the only movie that comes to mind
in the recent years is that there will
be blood where you follow daniel blamed
you so meticulously you know
it's not a it's not an easy thing to do
you know
um
100
uh it totally works uh i heard a rumor
and i want to know if it's true
uh i first of all kate is fantastic in
the movie uh but i heard that the
direction that you had her
acting like like she was in a film noir
and everyone else was given different
instructions
is that true
well what what we knew what i knew is
that i needed a difference
between the first half and the second
half
you know so what i said to kate is you
should move and
you should move as if you're a big cat
is it like a tiger or a lion you know
that's how carefully she moves in her
space
you know and then on the day i said and
then we're gonna crack
that facade a little bit
but i thought in my mind the carnival
needed to be
almost neo-realistic noir you know and
then you go to the city and with the
city you get
like the carnival has a very
uh
very
small orchestration on the score to give
you an example and then you go to the
city and the score becomes lush
and the and the carnival is full of warm
colors
saturated reds and there's no more red
in the city
the only reds in the city are molly's
dress
blood the lips of lilith
and the salvation army sign that's it
you can watch the movie as many times as
you want and those are the only reds
and the elevators light i guess
but the idea is all warmth is left
behind
and therefore the city is very well
represented by straight lines
by
cold textures like steel glass mirrors
polish black floors and lilith
lily's the character
is the largest shark in the tank
in the sense that stan thinks he's a big
fish
and
the city puts him on his rightful place
you know and i i i wanted
with kate to
to to walk in
the more genre elements of the movie the
to to bring in
sort of an evocation of all those
you know great
actresses in the 30s and 40s you know
to me one of the things
with this cause is
unlike the
the noir the traditional noir the femme
fadal
uh needs a punishment or something goes
wrong and i said let's make this an
omphadel
and let me let the three women
not only survive him but thrive
after he's gone you know and and
basically the downfall occurs to him you
know and and and i i i thought
kate had a very difficult act balancing
the
icy surface and the moments of
vulnerability and anger and pain
that the character has
i love talking about the editing process
as you know because that's ultimately
where it all comes together yeah right
it's the typewriter that's where you
that's where you ride the movie for the
first time
absolutely um so you mentioned you had a
longer cut uh what was the cut you had
that you're like i don't know how we're
gonna get this shorter do you know what
i mean was it that three hour 19 version
you're like oh this is really good
yeah well look i i was perfectly happy
with the movie at 3 15.
and but but what i knew look all it
takes is to show it
to somebody outside the circle you know
i think um
all it takes is
to to show it to even 20 people
and you immediately feel
the
slowness or the
bakeries of the story you know so we had
to lose
approximately
40 minutes of the carnival and
approximately
20 30 minutes of the
of the city which was a big big big big
challenge and i invited as i always do i
invited the most immediate circle into
into the editing room
and
and and show those things try everything
my my philosophy in the editing is you
can you can and should try anything
and then if you don't like it you can
always undo it that's the advantage of
the digital and then we switch things
from one place to another and eventually
ended up close to or far away from the
original position of a scene or two that
but those are what i call hinges
you know if you move a hinge
and the movie
let's say for example on the beginning
you know to give you an example
um went to work for zina
a lot later than it is right now
a lot of
more intervening scenes occurred in the
middle and i said there is a progression
there we
we found if we move him forward and he's
already working for her really quick
there's a hinge the audience goes oh
that changed that's it doesn't change
it's like uh now i'm ready to learn new
things as opposed to i'm on the old
scene
is is i found that in the editing is not
how long
a movie is is how many steps
are between a and b and b and c
the brisker those steps
the better the movie moves
and that 219 is is
is the only movie i've done that is more
than two hours
oh man i didn't even realize that yeah
i've never done more than two hours
i'm always 159
59 max
sure uh as a fan of nightmare alley and
the performances and the cinematography
and the production design and the list
goes on and on and on
will
you ever
show those as like
will the stuff you cut do you i guess
will i ever see it will fans ever see it
my look i i i said it on the on the dvd
of uh an earlier movie that i said the
the deleted scenes are deleted for a
reason
and and in the in the case of nightmare
alley they flash out the characters
sometimes
in a direction that doesn't suit
the rest of the narrative
uh if i
could in an ideal way
repace the movie i would still pace it
the way it is right now
you know because because i think
what you should and what you
end up with are two two different things
if you if you if you wrote exactly the
movie you shot and you shoot exactly the
movie you edited
a
i really
would take exception to that
i would say
it's almost a it's almost a really
it's a very purgatorial exercise
you know i get it i think when the movie
talks is when the movie is alive for me
after 30 years of doing this i find that
the movies that are much
er more worthy
of tangling
with are the movies that talk back to
you and say we need this
let me ask you this question what was
the last thing that you cut out before
you picture locked and why
i cut out little gestures i you know one
of the things that i felt was extremely
important we
we
knew that stan was going to be silent
for a long time and and um
[Music]
and his first words
and where he speaks them for the first
time
was very crucial
and the last one of the last things
that came out of the movie was
he used to say
a small line
before he talks to the geek inside of a
fun house
and
it felt
it felt
too minor and so
you know the ideal thing was to take it
out and find a way
for the scene
to flow without it that was both
challenging and fun
and that was the last thing
he had a very small line
where he accepts the job basically that
ron perlman offers him
and
and it was
challenging to cut around it
but we did and and and when we go to the
fun house
uh that's the first time he talks is in
the dark to the geek which is basically
a mirror
you know of yeah of his future and and
the movie the movie was
pregnant uh with with mirrors circles
alleys
and it was so much better for me that
the first time he spoke was in the
darkness
i've spoken to so many filmmakers and
they talk about how they wish they could
have a break in the shoot to analyze the
footage see what they have and then go
forward and unfortunately with kovid you
shot for a little while and then you had
a very long break and then you
eventually started filming again i'm
curious how did the film benefit from
that shutdown and how did things change
as a result
well look uh
first of all is is
it's kind of difficult for me to
see
this without
the disproportionate dimension of the
pandemic we had
put everything in perspective first of
all it became about
keeping yourself and
people safe and and that gave
uh that
that gave the break
um a calendar we we we thought first
it's gonna be nine weeks
and it wasn't it was six months
you know and and uh
it was really
uh
within that
stop watch
you know
uh two things happen i gained 60 pounds
from kovid covered the routine which
meant you went from the sofa to the
kitchen and back to the soap
you know for many many months because we
could not cross a border
uh it was locked down in toronto
and uh you know and that that happened
and then the other thing that happened
is
we were able to play with the material
of the second half of the movie which is
what we shot first
for a longer longer time
and and
stan became clearer
uh and it became clearer what we needed
on the first half
to
see him uh
become the guy that we had already shot
you know
uh bradley cooper was able to lose about
15 pounds
uh from the second half to the first
part i found those 15 pounds on more
rooney rooney gave birth to a baby
and when she came back
uh
she was a different
molly
somebody more that that felt really
connected to the earth really grounded
uh and the structure of the second half
uh made it clear that everything in the
movie everything in the movie was a
prologue to the last
two minutes the last close-up
you know
it was written like that originally in
the screenplay it says and now comes the
final shot blah blah blah and this the
camera doesn't cut blah blah blah
but
when you see when you see the material
it became clear that everything was
prolog
to that moment because that's that's the
biggest difference between the two
versions if you may
one of the biggest differences is
we see
almost relief
at the end
in his situation
is he finally knows who he is
you know as opposed to
the first version which is
an almost biblical punishment
to him
yeah i can't i will for people that are
watching i will not spoil the ending i
will just say the ending is [ __ ]
awesome and that shot is phenomenal um
and i don't want to say more than that
until people have seen it but that is a
shot i was
i i say bravo sir on that on that final
shot no
it was very tempting it was very
tempting
to
to
add this or add that that's the thing
one of the things the movie did that was
so curious man because i've never had
that
i caught shape of water in silence
without temp score and i got this mostly
without damn score but
it rejected score
the movie said no no no no and it took
more than a year to find
where and how much
the score was needed you know yeah the
the ending is so good in this um and
it's because man i don't want to say
because you you are the whole movie is
is is building towards that ending which
you don't anyway i i don't want to talk
about it because i wanted people to say
but the thing that you know when when
when you have uh
when you have a fantasy element you have
whimsical elements that come with it
there is already an ingenuity
and in a character that doesn't exist or
a situation that doesn't exist
that allows the ma the mind to escape
and what happened in this movie is
actually with this tillage
as the movie goes
it becomes more and more distilled and
then
you start the movie with a
guy alone and you end the movie with a
guy
alone in a different way you know it's
it's really it was very for example one
element that was very
very much found
in the editing uh the the dreams he has
uh
were
more we shot much more we could have
revealed this and that and connect and
and and we decided to make it a few
images
that almost repeat themselves
and and they add one to the other to the
other until the until you understand
what happened
in that cabin
in the opening shot and that was the
other thing you say what was the last
thing you
subtracted or added you know one
there was the second shot of the movie
which is not the shot that is there was
a beautiful crane
gorgeous gorgeous shot
he went from him to his feet to a
gasoline can follow the trail of
gasoline into a body it was really
amazing and it was the second shot of
the movie but it felt like a shot
you know
it was so good
but it was very showy
and
that went because
you could not start the movie like that
there was a power and a simplicity to
the first shot
and then the shot of the burning cabin
that demanded sort of a
a bear down
uh
sensibility
i thought that you and dan did such a
great job uh working together on the
visual aesthetic of the film and we've
already touched on on some of the colors
and everything else but could you sort
of talk about a little bit more of the
aesthetic of of how you wanted the film
to look and working with dan to achieve
that
well one of the things that
people when the movie is available in
for home
and one of the things that i beg people
if they can do it is to watch the movie
in black and white because what we did
is we used
very traditional cross lighting
uh so that the movie is lit like a black
and white movie and was our directed
with a lot of uh reds and greens and
gold
which gives you all the midtones in the
gray right
so it was almost like a black and white
movie
that was done in color like a
stereograph
like imagine that you're printing the
ink layer that's the black and white and
then you print the color layer that's
the movie that you saw uh that was one
of the things we said let's do cross
lighting
like in the in the traditional movies
we lowered the ceilings in a lot of the
scenes so the camera was able to see the
characters and the ceiling
uh the ceilings were a little over six
feet tall
but so they were very present
and then we decided to uh shoot the
movie as much as possible uh
in wanners
like there's a lot of shots that are a
single shot
and it's a staged with the actors like
like a movie from the 40s you know
actors come close and away from the lens
the camera follows them to and from a
thing
and that that is also
a decision that
has to do with the fact that
um
it's how this guy is illuminated by the
characters we thought
let bradley be a negative space like a
black hole
led by different characters that we give
him three fathers
and we even three mothers so to speak
and they illuminate him in the middle as
a negative space and and we needed to
keep the integrity of that choreography
to say it's all about these interactions
it's not about
uh it's not just about style it's about
let's preserve the interaction between
him and the characters
it's interesting you say watching it in
black and white i i would love to do
that but i don't necessarily know that
when it eventually comes out i guess
maybe on blu-ray um
well i mean i don't want to get ahead of
myself but is that something that you're
thinking about in terms of because it's
hard on the streamers they generally
don't give you that option
i would love to yeah i would love to and
we are exploring
the look of that
uh i mean i i watched one of the things
that happened during the pandemic is
that
i started
watching
the dailies when we came back i watched
them in black and white on my macbook
i i went to grayscale
and i watched them i started watching
all the dailies in black and white
and i finally
started to
publicly say
you guys should look at it this way
because that's that's
that was how dan and i would squint in
the monitor
and and love the lighting because we
were reproducing
a very expressionist lighting in the
night
that was keeping all the midtones
yeah i i loved the cinematography and
the look one of the things that i felt
and i was saying this um to someone is
that i watching the movie i just felt
transported to like another time and
place i never thought about real life i
never thought about my phone i just was
captivated beginning to end and
uh one of the reasons is because the
carnival is just so
well built and designed
and yeah and in that whole i mean i just
disappeared into it can you sort of talk
about creating that on obviously a
budget because you're not making some
marvel movie with this material you
obviously have a finite amount of money
no yeah i mean in the last few years
you get period movies that cost up to
150 160
million blah blah blah and you know we
knew we were a searchlight movie we had
a budget that we needed to
do by very judiciously building big sets
and when it was needed we we had sets
that were amazing lilith's office uh
greenville's office
uh the copacabana uh
back uh
all the
dressing rooms and all that but but we
also scouted very very carefully and
then
what we decided early on with wardrobe
production design
and the art department they said let's
layer that really really really well
let's not have just guys in suits and
fedoras
and and women in
clothes
for city clothes we
layered everything
i went on ebay myself and i started
buying
props and set dressing
that i brought to the movie um that i
made sure there was a an accurate i
bought all the bills
all the cash that appears in the movie i
bought first
i wanted to find the
cache that looked used i got a lighting
fixtures in lilith's office vending
machines
blah blah blah and
and we when you go to a carnival
you have to get the the period popcorn
bags the period balloons the period
strings for the balloons the period
carnival prices
uh if you see a wall of cupidols you
have to get cupidos from the period
you have to get a period carnival uh
merry-go-round you have to
the the fastenings
on the tent
are made of leather and brass leather
umbra is machined
for the period
the way you hang the banners the the
everything ever there was no modern
hardware the the all the kitchen the
cooking
implements and then we had to
differentiate
the the way people dressed in
in in the urban environment in the city
and the way people dressed in the
carnival and we used layers we had
people in leather jackets we had people
in denim jackets we had women in working
clothes we had women in their best
sunday clothes
it was so layered and
and then we had to to choose
every single prop
and run it against a
sort of um you would say um
a system
that that qualified it and said yeah
it's of the period we we cannot we
cannot be inaccurate then uh
just layering the
the the
the props with the characters all the
women needed to have a little handbag
all the men needed to have a
handkerchief
all that because back then
uh
you had to have it and one that's one of
the things that i i tell you one
two things i i i'm marveled at bradley
because i think this is a a very
different role than anything he's ever
done one of the first things i said to
him is you had to take boxing
and he went into boxing lessons and he
was in the ring a couple of times a week
because i said uh if you went through
depression if you went through
uh
hopping trains
in the in the 30s
you were you got physical and and and
the way
a guy that had been on
on the lam or or
broke at that time included us
the way he owned the physical space and
the way he would own a confrontation
and he did it he went full-on the other
thing he did
which is absolutely marvelous to watch
is the way he handles cigarettes and
fedora on the fedora the way he puts it
on he
the way he falls it straightens the brim
the way he picks it up the way he picks
up and holds a cigarette which is
completely of the period and he does it
in two styles the sophisticated smoker
in the second half and the not
sophisticated smoker and the first and
he kept track of all these little things
and and i i i tell you those things are
invaluable the way you layer the period
with not just the props and the and the
sets and but the gestures
the way
the way
the way for example kate
talks
is not an imitation
but she completely delivers
uh
a
sort of mid-atlantic
uh very polished accent
oh they're both fantastic do you think
that bradley um his experience directing
has changed him as an actor um because
oh sorry yeah no doubt i mean look
if you ask me a bradley's a director
that acted
is a guy that you can talk
he knows exactly what the lens is
looking at yes that's one advantage like
he would say do you want me to cross the
lens he always stayed in the composition
he knew
where the shot ended and where his
physical space started all that is great
but also what is amazing is then you
have a partner
in the whole process you this is another
guy that is worried about his part
he knows exactly where in the movie this
is
what it means
uh why the why why
do it in a whiner and not in coverage
why why there will be no close-up here
or why he will reject the close-up and
say i think he played on the white and i
go i think you're right let's move on
you know this is that's never happened
to me
you know and and and there was no
wrangling expectations because he knows
where the direction is going
you know you're not wrangling the
expectations of a star
you're you're
you're actually you have a full partner
that understands
editing lighting everything is
i think
we went through
we said this jokingly we went through a
10-year friendship
in three years
you know
we
are now friends for life
and we've gone through every up and down
there is in the book
because i'm basically out of time i'm
just gonna ask you one last thing um
just as a fan of your work i know you're
hard at work at pinocchio um and
obviously i cannot wait to see it uh for
fans of yours uh what would you like to
tease them about the project what do you
want them to know about pinocchio well
look it's it's a very
it's a very very very very personal
movie for me
the two the flip sides for me i've
always been pinocchio and frankenstein
of the same story because essentially
that's the same story you know
and and and the idea of
uh a pinocchio
that
talks about uh
things that i consider very deep
but it is fun and it's a musical at the
same time
but i find it really really
incredibly moving obviously in animation
you get to see the movie in storyboards
beginning to end
many many times and then you add the
stop motion
and right now we are about
50 percent animated and 50 in
storyboards
and every time i watch the movie
i just saw
like like a baby you know it's it's
as personal as it gets
as moving as it gets
and it's not uh
it's not it's unlike any other version
of the story you've ever seen it's
completely unlike it and and and and
it's a bird it subverts the
the
moral underpinnings of the original
fable
which which is in order to
be a real boy you got to change
and you got to become flesh and blood
and you got to become this is about
becoming a real boy by
by
acting on a real human i would say by
acting like a real human period
do you do you think it'll be out uh like
a year from now or oh yeah no the movie
will come out last quarter of 2022 so
is is curious because it's been almost
five years
since shape of water and now uh it's
gonna be two movies in a row one after
the other
i [ __ ] love it i'm just just being
honest